Christie is not running for president of
the United States ever he was arguably
running for like vice president of New
Hampshire but anyway once he exited
we'll actually combine that in to prop
up Nikki a little bit more the next
thing is you take the Ronda santis Ronda
s is not in New Hampshire so much but in
certain other states Florida or
otherwise turn that over as well to the
anti-trump movement I don't think Ron
knows that I think if people asked Ron
de santis he would say of course I would
not be Nikki's vice president and I
think inside him he probably would
believe that that's actually what he
thinks but that almost pretends that
what he thinks actually matters his
donors are the on that put him up to run
for president in the first place I don't
think the man on his own valtion I think
there are other people who put him up to
run for president at a time where it
didn't make for sense for him to do it
the same people are going to put him up
to be Nikki's vice president so you play
this forward that's where this goes
final step take Trump out of contention
Trot the corporate puppets into office
that's where this plot ends and I feel
like I see this with a level of clarity
that makes it torturous it's like a kind
of form of torture to watch this playing
out in real time